I'm concerned about getting the truth I
don't Tark individuals Target
individuals you're targeting Hunter
you're targeting an individual you know
part of the problem and this is pretty
obvious to anybody watching this is you
don't invite me on to interview me you
invite me on to argue with me you know
I'm just trying to lay out the facts
that certainly Senator grass and I
uncovered they were suppressed they were
censored they interfered in the 2020
election conservatives understand that
unfortunately liberals in the media
don't and that's part of the things that
part of the reasons are politics are
inflamed is we do not have an unbiased
uh media we don't it's unfortunate I'm
all for free press more unbiased there's
misinformation
look you can go back on your partisan
cable a cocoon and talk about media bias
all you want I understand it's part of
your identity